mark is in New York City hey Mark
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
Dave how are you better than I deserve
sir what's up
um I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
cool I think I think you hit the nail on
the head I've worked very very hard on
my life and very intelligent at the end
the day I look and I have no savings
living from paycheck to paycheck I've
been inspired listening to you in the
last two three months
I just I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired of a daughter that's gonna be
going off to college she's very very
intelligent and I wanted to give her
every advantage to go to that college
that unfortunately there's going to be
things associated with paying for
college so I need some direction here as
far as what I do what I'm interested in
one of the books that you were
recommending I just not sure what the
name of the book was the very first
one's baby steps mm-hmm that would be
the total money makeover that walks you
through how to put how to walk how to
walk through the baby steps that we
teach the Total Money Makeover I'll give
you a copy as a Christmas present when
we finish talking okay so what do you
make a year well I don't make a whole
lot that's wet one time I made about
6065 but uh it because of the economy
crash in the building industry uh that's
been reduced and actually just started
working with a big major bank and I'm
sure that they'll come up right now I'm
only making about thirty okay are you
married I'm separated and actually I'm
taking care of two great kids full-time
and that that keeps me very busy and I
want to be able to do things with them
and for them you know but uh well I
don't have a lot of debt you do have a
lot of that no no no I don't have a lot
of good luck in that respect but the the
thing that I have an issue with is my
credits been affected through a couple
different things places I've stayed
where I couldn't maintain the rent and I
fell behind and that it I thought will
pick on my record but other than that uh
that's about it well I'm not really
worried about your credit I mean when
you make $30,000 you're trying to raise
two kids in New York City that's a tight
budget
that's an unbelievably tight budget so I
mean just the fact they're paying our
bills and eating is a big deal right
there
and so I'll give you permission to do
that for a little while as and so what I
would say is given your location you're
struggling more with income than
anything else and so as you continue to
heal your career I mean you went on a
downturn but that's not a permanent
downturn and as your income comes back
up in other words then you're going to
see this more and more margin happen
inside of your budget but the big thing
I tell folks and there's always a
central with everyone who wins with
money is they do a written game plan a
written budget and we've got that online
at every dollar every dollar calm is an
online budgeting tool it's completely
free to use jump on there and use that
and keep up with every dollar and make
every dollar behave make every dollar
have a name every dollar have a mission
and it doesn't do anything except that
managed money works harder when you have
a managed plan from a written gameplan
using something like every dollar com
then what happens is you get you get the
money you feel like you got a raise
because the money just works harder and
you need this money to work as hard as
you can get it to work 30 grand in new
york city is tough it's just tough and
so but and then as you learn how to live
on that as your income comes up that's
going to feel like extra freed up money
you're going to be in just great shape
to do all kinds of cool things so yeah
that's exactly the way I would look at
it and more than anything if I'm in your
shoes in your location I'm going to be
working on the income side of the
equation but make the outgo side make it
behave with a very detailed in-depth
budget and that that's every dollar calm
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others
Oh